jodie aujourd'hui sauf pour deux vidéos
sur agger aurelio parce que je suis
tombé à dicter à ce jeu c'est parti on
va s'appeler je suis très vilain vilain
parce qu'on peut pas mettre de haine
ces versements voir si on a du style
aujourd'hui ça fait une semaine que j'ai
pas joué et je suis plutôt enjoué
bonjour au royal va lui faire croire
qu'il peut donc quand je suis tout petit
coin les mecs qui ce speed pour ça ils
devraient avoir honte bordel il va pas
dormir cette nuit pas pq a très bien
dormir c'est au moins qu'ils aient pas
dormir regarde au delà poland mais quoi
mais s'il vous plaît un moment vous
allez arrêter de 1,2 me bizuté on va
essayer de grossir un peu psy avec moi
et je fais le malin est tout petit con à
pixels oh oui multiplient dans le
soutien aux salles jamais pas ressenti
c'est ce bon feeling depuis si longtemps
au regard des eaux fait ça avec les
tétons l'un est que les tt et se croient
malins ils croient malins non ça n'est
que des ados ça n'est que des ânes ou
non ça dit que rien je le touche
on sent sa peau sur la nôtre bien l'avez
vécu viala of violence vient
complètement fou mais quitte à mourir
revient dans mes bras mois masse c'est
pas grave tu voir le positif encore n'a
pas même qu'ont expliqué comme un gros
coup oui un coup de maître
attention aux plats qu'est ce qui
t'arrive tu as vu ce que tu ressens
quand tu sais manger c'est
indescriptible
c'est vraiment une sensation que tu
ressens quand tu manges seront plus
indescriptible non non
ah voilà ça t'as vu ça t'amuse pauv' con
batwa très gros il va nous avoir non
regardez il est suspecté
regardez le à elle s'en va bien tu as de
mettre la pression la tâche mauvaise au
oui mais voilà dans les bras d'un gros
voilà ok on sera sûr qu'activement au
oui mais c'est un vrai joueur par contre
l'autre mais pourquoi il a fait ça des
fois je comprends pas je comprends pas
les gens ont des vues tir de la partie
vu que demande le peuple
il faut qu'on soit premier c'est mon
objectif dans la vie et mon unique avoir
bon métier une copine tout ça on s'en
fout c'est un gars poillion notre ligne
directrice
bien à toi bâtard opus the do arrogants
ils respirent l'arrogance cet homme un
vraiment il aime provoquer et dans
l'excès bombes les notes et à tous les
hommes
allez vous-en les gros mais c'est moi à
oui avec vous partout il est énorme à
ses premières j'ai paniqué je suisse et
un portugais il a splitté pour s'en
sortir
ça va il a paniqué aussi c'est la
panique générale il ya du feu
des gens crient il ya une musique qui
fait peur ouais ouais ouais merci
boudreau débit on s'en est bien sorti on
s'en est bien sorti au final j'ai là
vous plaît ce qui s'est passé mais ça se
bouffe en masse en bas je n'abandonne
pas mon rêve d'être premier du game à
jour ne vous en faites pas regardez les
faire les malins voyage à l'édile fait
le malin mais les nuls les pourris les
gens pourris on les boeufs
[Musique]
max cabanes barre toi de moi comme ça je
dis oui
haumea garde pas york 13
il faut qu'on a décrié faut qu'on se
calme pour se détendre parce qu'on est
très vilain et qui était très vilain
détresse qui les voilà c'est c'est une
équation totalement fausses on s'en fout
si ce profil assez gros la salle amusant
mais venez vous avez peur de quoi quoi
il manquerait manger mais dès qu il a
mangé puisque défoncer les os les trucs
verts je vous ferai plus jamais
confiance à son j'aime pas le verse pas
du tout à une couleur que j'aime j'adore
le bleu le rouge le vert c'est new las
pour les cours je rage ouvrage pas du
tout en plus un mais c'est quoi alors
les doigts tag éditorial peuvent-ils
tentant de ne courir des bruits l'ofppt
la wii il s'appelait nouveaux joueurs en
plus le pauvre bien là toi il va falloir
je vis pas fait comme ça aux passants
marc yevou barack obama tu désolé matt
tu étais comme la transpiration de la
raie des fesses ça tu était inévitable
c'est bon ça comme métaphore c'est très
beau gars c'est ce que je te laisse te
bats toi tu fais quoi tu fais quoi tu
fais quoi
mais peine j'ai pas compris toutes
sortes de trucs mère mon gars on m'a
envoyé un truc vert dessus mais ça c'est
des trucs qui devrait pas exister je
suis désolé mon profiter mon gars je les
passais deux est de la galerie de
seconds le mec on n'est pas bien comme
ça qu'on est là juste plus je suis 6e
donc je ne s'applique plus je crois que
mes autres
[Musique]
c'est horrible bosses un truc comme ça
ce jeu est tellement bien et est
tellement dans l'addiction mais c'est
tellement frustrant c'est affreux quoi
quand il se passe un truc comme ça tu as
envie je sais pas moi de ne rien faire
pendant deux heures et demie tu as
l'impression quand une seconde ta vie
est devenue totalement nul ça va c'est
de ce split et de m'avoir aller qu'est
ce que j'avais déjà l'esquivé la
patience portera c'est oui allez roro
oui j'adore ça jérôme ce qui est un
petit dieu dans ce jeu qui t'offre des
fois des cadeaux will al hayat la bouffe
la ja de la bouffe mon gars oui on a
pris encore qu'une saga casse-toi web tu
dis un peu trop puissante 1 du coup j'ai
nourri un mec quoi sur les connais j'ai
fait la nourrice suis dégoûté voilà oui
mais c'était bien nul ça oui merci
deutschland or vois tu passeras pas tu
passeras pas tu passeras pas il est pas
passé bah c'est pas du tout dans le
rythme je voulais me contenir faire le
mec sobre mais non je suis pas comme ça
c'est pas nous on cherche mais on prend
pas la grosse tête sur un gars poillion
on est les mêmes qu'avant les mêmes
qu'au début avant qu'on soit sixième du
classement
c'est je me rend fou c'est un truc de
dingue ça joue sur les nerfs et sur
surtout en fait ça c'est fou on est
quatrièmes les gens on est de plus en
plus haut dans la liste mondiale premier
les non non c'est impossible que sa
première balle fait tout l'écran c'est
pas possible
oui merci moon au les [ __ ] m'aurait
jamais les gars vous la regardiez ya
regarde ce que tu fais jahia espace de
co
oh oui oh merci voilà sa petite
récompense à pourra vraiment le coeur
qui bat vite au jeu de l'en but spitz et
parce qu'on va arriver dans le coin en
bas à droite il m'a [ __ ] il manie qu'a
le connard j'ai juste sacrifier un bout
de moi même
manon est vraiment pourquoi ça marche
pas comme ça dans la vie
allez basta tout perdu parce que tu as
été content
[Musique]
ouf